[Music]
history is actually the one thing I
think which allows you to get out ahead
it's very ironic because then people
think about history they think well
history means that things are going on
in the world and historian is off
reading dusty books which you know fair
enough I would love to be reading lots
of dusty books right now I will concede
the point but when you've read all those
dusty books what happens is that you
have the ability to see certain patterns
you have a sense of what fits together
and what doesn't fit together Isaiah
Berlin wrote an essay on the possibility
of a scientific history in which he may
said that history is not about knowing
what happened it's about knowing what
can't happen right that is extremely
useful so a historian will never look at
a problem and say this is entirely new a
story will look at a problem and try to
find the familiar aspects of it and
that's a that's a very big advantage
over certain for other forms of analysis
because if you look at something and say
that it's totally new that disables the
mind right away it also tends to disable
I think political action because if
something's totally new it's very easy
to take the next step and say well if
it's totally new then what can I do
about it or you can say since it's
totally new all things are permitted
which can also lead you in some really
unproductive directions so the first
thing that historian will do is we'll
say whatever this problem is it's not
entirely new when a historian is
confronted by something very surprising
like the 2016 campaign and United States
the historian is is is is likely to say
well the things that this candidate er
is saying aren't true but the
possibility this kind of campaign could
work is a real possibility
so the historian is is freed from or
should be freed from the the the
conviction of the day and the historian
looks it automatically looks back to
other moments where similar things like
this coalesced so for example we're in a
second globalization there was a first
globalization in the late 19th and early
20th century
the second globalization began our
globalization began with all kinds of
promises that technology and export led
growth would lead to enlightenment and
liberalism the first globalization did
two the first globalization crashed it
crashed into the first world war the
Great Depression the second world war
Stalinism the Holocaust a historian
looking at today you know won't think
well that whole pattern is gonna repeat
itself but their store the can today can
say yeah a politician who says that
globalization is a problem out of
solution a politician who says that
globalization is a matter of particular
people plotting against us as opposed to
objective threats to the country or
objective problems that kind of
politician has a chance that can work
things like that have worked before and
once you see that it can come together
that way it's not that you're sure it's
something you predict it but although I
have made some predictions that were
right but it's it's it's more that you
can see it coming together and then that
allows you to get out ahead and you can
think okay well if this is going to come
together this way then I can also steal
from the past people's correct reactions
to it or people's wise reactions to it I
can I can use those things from the
failure of the first globalization I can
just borrow them I can now extract them
and put them in the 21st century which
is what I did in maan tyranny so you can
rather than saying okay I'm gonna wait
for this pack because by the time the
pattern actually coalesce is it's too
late right you have to see that the
pattern might be coalescing and then
start messing with the pattern that the
way that you see it coalescing comes
from history and the tools that you use
to start messing with it also come from
history so in that way ironically a
history can allow you to get out ahead
of something whereas you know the
journalists naturally have to describe
it that's their job in the political
side the social scientists they're gonna
wait to categorize it and they're kind
of trapped right I mean that's another
irony is that historians are comfortable
with novelty because we know things
change all the time right when your
perspective is a thousand years or even
a hundred years you know stuff changes
you know there are turning points and
you know that the stuff which people
thought was unbelievable yesterday will
not only be believable
we'll even seem normal today right any
historian can see that so that that
gives us a certain that gives us a
certain edge I think the second thing
that a historian will do is that
historian will be skeptical about
sources so if you say the problem is X a
historian will instantly you know
his or her head and think okay well this
person says the problem is X but let's
cast our minds out immediately to try to
think of what the other fifteen relevant
perspectives on this problem are is it
actually a problem it maybe it's
something which is desirable from
certain points of view right so that's
it that's that's a methodological reflex
that whatever your first-person
perspective is that's not the truth for
me the truth automatically has to come
from comparing your perspective to a
whole bunch of other perspectives and
that's useful also because it can
preserve the dynamism and the urgency of
something while taking some of the
subjective spin from it so ideally a
historian or historically trained person
is less likely to be played by the
presentation of a problem and more
likely to you know skeptically figure
out what its what its contours are and
then the third advantage that historians
have and maybe this is the one which I
find to be most relevant in the present
is that historians see time as a flow or
is something which is continuous and
this is incredibly important now because
that the way that the news cycle works
or the way that what I call the politics
of eternity works is that you get your
brain bludgeoned every day by the
emotions of the moment as transmitted by
very skilled political actors through
very efficient media and the result is
that it's so easy to either be elated or
outraged every day and to experience the
day is a kind of complete unit where you
know you wake up you're shocked you're
outraged and then by the end of the day
you're out you're dissipated you're
exhausted and then you just begin the
cycle again historians don't believe in
cycles or at least good historians don't
believe in cycles historians think that
they're there there are long-term
patterns however however exciting or
however exhausting are however
terrifying the thing is today it's part
of some longer
sweep right so to give an example me to
give an extreme example even nuclear war
so in the last few months the subject of
nuclear war has come up from all kinds
of directions even nuclear war has a
history you know there's only there's
only been one and that was in 1945 and
there have been a lot of moments where
it was likely or less likely like Cuba
so even something which is dramatic and
which is as it were designed to shock
you out of thinking in time even that
can be put in some kind of a context the
things in other words that the weapons
that are designed to get you to stop
thinking like let's be afraid of the
foreigner so let's be afraid of nuclear
war if you think about those threats
over time as part of some kind of larger
flow you're less likely to be disabled
and you're more likely to distinguish
the rhetoric from what might actually be
the risk
[Music]